well there are many unanswered questions
about the moment we're living in it's a
very confusing one but increasingly on
the Left there's only one right answer
to any question racism racism is
everywhere they're telling us it's the
sum total of everything for many
liberals charging racism has become an
almost involuntary habit a tic like
saying god bless you after somebody
sneezes they may not even be aware
they're doing it watch for example as
noted TV person Jeffrey Toobin reduces
the complicated meteorological
phenomenon of hurricanes to a single
word yes
racism isn't the story that these people
who died apparently thousands of them in
Puerto Rico 3,000 as you point out
they're not white people and they don't
count to Donald Trump as much as the
deaths of white people I mean I hate to
say that about someone but look at his
record isn't that indicative of who he
is and what he said I don't know it's
not an especially surprising point lots
of media people say things like this
every day what's so striking about this
is that Jeff Toobin is doing it he's not
a bad guy personally I've always liked
him for whatever it's worth and unlike
so many other people you see on
television he is not stupid in fact
Toobin once wrote the single best
account of the OJ Simpson trial that's a
book that these days he himself would
likely dismiss as you guessed it racist
and that's actually the point like an
awful lot of other people Jeff Toobin is
a product of the current moment which
also happens to be the dumbest moment in
American history and speaking of dumb
that's actually what the president
called Maxine Waters it's a claim
supported by some evidence but to Jeff
Toobin well you can imagine but just how
about this Maxine water stuff over and
over again low IQ how racist is the
juban didn't explain how that's racist
in fact if you need to ask you probably
voted for Donald Trump which means
you're racist too you know what a lot of
people like the fact that he's racist
and and that's the thing that that we
need to acknowledge so how racist is
Donald Trump so racist that when he
criticizes a group of political
extremists comprised almost entirely of
upper-middle class
white kids that's racist too huh well
yeah because the white kids wear black
clothing get it black clothing which of
course Trump hates because the clothing
is black racism again let's be clear
also about what's going on here
the theme here is I'm Donnie Donald
Trump and I'll protect you from the
scary black people and Tifa is widely
perceived as an african-american
organization this is about black versus
white this is about Donald Trump's
appeal to racism and yet another cable
television appearance Toobin called
Donald Trump races for criticizing
Elizabeth Warren who like those in Tifa
kids is also white but also doesn't want
to admit it pretty funny some never
gonna wake up though from all this
insanity and wonder what the hell
happened how do we get so stupid video
clips like these will make for very
embarrassing time capsules like that bad
tattoo on your leg or that tape of the
rehearsal dinner when you got you drunk
and insulted the bride
it seemed like a good idea at the time
Oh